you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 500
game okay
White is already starting off with a
pretty modest set up so I can get away
with just quickly getting out my light
square bishop and I think I will make
another Bishop move and not even allow
some type of minor piece and bounce I
have to be on the lookout for efore this
is a way to justify or put to use these
moves that I've given light against my
bishop f3 e4 so with that said let me
look to strike at d4
this is not yet a move let's immediately
put pressure on the center maybe even
the diagonal with Queen to b6 huh I can
also try for a Bishop d6 in a push let's
try for that he four is still not
working
mmm there is some idea with maybe Queen
f3 hitting at f7 and b7 now they're
prepping e4
let's go here on Queen g3l preparing
preparing to go Queen side this is a pin
Queen g3 okay they're not going for that
but I was prepared to give up my Jeep on
so this is just fine for me now no
issues and white is allowing me to give
them an isolated pawn I like it let's do
this maybe not here my bishop is
unprotected yeah I guess that's what
they're thinking of but still even
position I would say Bishop g5 is maybe
a move okay Knight - D - it is I could
just castle though or what about Queen
to d3 yeah that seems pretty active
let's do Queen d3 doesn't allow a a
piece to recapture here Knight takes
Knight takes Queen takes Falls for mate
okay so now you got to take with the
pawn and where exactly - castle probably
Kings side and defend f7 anything better
I don't see it so I could look to just
play against this guy here you can't
find such a safe square
maybe rook after three challenging my
bishop okay let's go here I'm going with
this rook because of what I see an f7 is
being sensitive rook d1 here okay let's
stay active with my queen keeping
pressure on the pawn on a two and also
d4 I guess there is b3 but Queen here
how are we doing on the clock and down
just a tad both of us still need a
flight square soon to be a position
where it's just major pieces alone let's
get here right away just looking to poke
at the e4 pawn this is the only thing I
could play for is against the structure
so flight Square wise I'm leaning
towards h6 as soon as the bishops are
off however maybe g6 is better dark
square and right now they are in a pin I
could take advantage of this and I will
be winning upon
and I'll probably just take rook here
maybe you look up seven no they want
rook here I guess that's not something
that scares me though let's defend my
seventh and I'll so prepare to get here
once more with rook to e7 maybe this was
better actually so I could swing my rook
over to the sixth rank and have them be
an attacker maybe against H too you know
hmm yeah I have to reorganize Queen you
know what I could do I could go Queen
here yeah let's hang out here rook takes
pawn takes takes with check now I'm not
going to be there to Queen so okay I
guess I have to do this staying on this
square I think this is the flight square
white would want g3 exposes the King to
another diagonal so both of us really
ideally like the H pawn moves for flight
squares I'm looking to consolidate my
structure with b6
what is that moment I have rook down to
f1 they just had a serious brain cramp
I'm assuming he takes pawn rook to f1
yeah but really the opening was
something was off there with the opening
clearly got simplified quite a bit as
you saw major piece ending alone let's
go into the analysis I think they were
too quick with and another earlier moves
and trying to get an e4 if efore wasn't
in at the right moment then black is at
least equal at least comfortable I mean
as you saw I had something to play
against and that's all it was it was
playing against a structure so yeah as
mentioned it's a modest approach by
white in the opening so
allows me to do this if c4 is played you
know this this you know going with
excuse me if c4 is played here this idea
to get the bishop outside the pawn chain
is a little bit more tricky to get in I
mean we're not in this exact position
but I mean let me put it like this state
it like this if at this point instead of
the Bishop d3 move if c4 bring the
bishop out early like this is always a
bit questionable because of the reply
Queen b7 however in the game I get to
play this and there is no Counter Strike
let's say meeting the threat against the
Queen with Queen to b3 so I like going
for this just to get the bishop outside
the pawn chain I make several bishop
moves but I'm trading off my bad bishop
for their good Bishop and this is the
only thing I have to be on the lookout
for can they say you know these this
tempo against my bishop with f3 is
something they could put to use by
expanding in the center that remains to
be seen
maybe instead of c3 they could have
really tried to force through this
advance with Queen e2 right now
maybe Queen e2 at this moment and if I
go c5 c3 Bishop here now this this is
maybe a better approach for white
basically to get in a form but because
of c3 and this King move which was just
kind of uh I don't know I think this is
the this is the move that really makes
things difficult for white because
they're not able to get an e4 in a
timely way
you know once it did hit I wasn't afraid
of it because at that point I could
satellite with an isolated and isolated
pawn
but Queen here instead now if I'm doing
this I have to be afraid of getting
forked one day e 5 and yeah it's a much
different story now but they just
instinctually pulled the King off of
this diagonal but I think they could
look forward to getting an e for right
now instead the King move because of it
I'm able to get in my own a 5 pawn break
first and now when this move hits
they're gonna end up with an isolated
pawn like we saw in the game notice if I
was not playing e5 at this moment here
and just going with castles then what am
i doing now you know I'm not able to
saddle white with an isolated pawn in
this case I could take recapture I'm
just helping white by doing that I could
take again but now I'm having to work
around these two guys much different
story
I have to maybe play e5 and then there's
maybe a connected past pawn so I have to
be timely playing e5 and as mentioned on
this move I was prepared to sack up on
and I think that there would certainly
be compensation here
I'm fully developed white is behind and
I have a file to play play with here on
the G file right towards the king in a
very nice center so I thought that this
may be a possibility because for the
moment my bishop on d6 is unprotected
this stuff but as it was played out I
just have didn't mean to go all the way
back
many times I would do this just allow
the night for Bishop exchange but I
don't know I just wanted to trade good
for bad Bishop this is also probably
quite reasonable you know I still have a
bishop that fits in well with my
structure Bishop on dark pawns on light
but you know made a lot of bishop moves
one two three four but uh yeah maybe I
shouldn't have done that we'll have a
look at it with stockfish sorted out but
you know definitely take black in this
type of position any day
it's black the one blacks the one who's
playing against the structure and they
have to do awkward stuff already to
defend the pawn and I guess I'm winning
it you know he is hit twice how to
defend him and I know they're in a pen
and maybe I could have done something
better instead of rook to f7 maybe
record f6 looking for these ideas but
this is just a solid approach rook f7
defending the back rank and well I'm up
upon and they just ended up wandering
here Queen takes rook if play followed
they are mated okay well let's just
double-check things with stockfish and
see at that early moment where there are
some improvements
okay stockfish let's see about this
early stage of the game any issues with
how it was played top recommendation is
not to take the bishop but many perfect
perfectly reasonable moves at this point
little shift at all in this game Knight
B to d7 is fine as well as Bishop to e7
I get in c5 yeah and this is just a
nothing position however now there is I
mean it is a minor shift but there is
some shift this uh like give something
up by making this mm prophylactic type
move I don't think this is a position
where that prophylactic safety type move
is it's not a good moment for that
there needs to be a better build up more
development needs to be on board for
white before they opt for came to h1 so
computers suggesting night to d2 I was
pointing out Queen to e2 similar idea in
minds with supporting the e4 advance
night to d2 because of King h1 there is
now a little something now for black
Bishop e7 suggested Bishop d6 it's fine
as well Queen there ends it's not
recommending a 5 let's see if ePHI vis
okay
b5 is okay G takes Knight takes Knight
takes Bishop takes you know it's just
maybe a little something here for black
you for takes in Bishop g5 I thought
that that might be a move you know
Queen d3 elects in reply to the knight
move but let's consider the Bishop g5
move because if white ends up with an
isolated pawn it's black who's
definitely the the better side and
playing for something so Bishop g5
undermines the support on e4 castles
Knight d2 so just getting the bishop out
before the night and still taking
advantage of this little pin against my
unprotected bishop there is no pawn
takes Queen takes bishop
guess a better way for white to develop
at this stage Bishop out first in the
night - D - as soon as was here it's uh
it's white who has the isolated pond and
yeah I end up picking up the pond it's
as simple as that so it's really just
the middlegame decision that allowed
black to create a target within white
structure and then pinpoint it it's an
even issue valuation but you'll find
that any player really would prefer
black here this isn't this isn't some
positive in the white position to have
this pond around wants to go with rook
to f5 here it's tough to play as white
both of us still need to work on our
back rank issue needing a flight square
but the issue for white is pointed at
this guy here
f5 is picking up the pawn and yeah they
just blundered here in the end that's
rook takes pawn not much more to really
say so kawaiii came to start and it's
again the early point regarding the
structure I had the isolated pawn and I
had something to bite at as a result
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video and in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you